titoff et jette pas là seulement pour
faire votre promo ah bon ben non vous
êtes là aussi pour tester les nouvelles
interviews que je vais faire après des
vraies stars ya pas de problème y'a pas
de problème vous est pris on va faire
l'interview sigla on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
m
pour vous le progrès ces tgv ou ivg
et toi tu vas le faire des vraies stars
ouais
je vais cependant je prends mon premier
joker jean-pierre ouais je vais donner
l'avis du public ouais est ce que la
démocratie a plus à craindre de letea ou
de l'ena
le nom lainages et une fois j'ai joué
j'ai joué dans une école pour une école
c'est le polytechnique c'est incroyable
ce speed un truc de fou quand j'avais
pas fini les phrases ils rigolaient déjà
il avait déjà compris la gran ils sont
impressionnants ils font peur
notre vie sexuelle
votre vie sexuelle c'est plutôt sas
ras ou sos c'est plutôt s
sas ouais bah ouais tant qu'à faire
maintenant que j'y suis puisque chaque
fois je dis je passe pour un obsédé
votre vision de la vie conjugale c'est
plutôt cdd cdi ou sdf
en ce moment c'est ce qui m'inquiète
c'est plutôt cdi mais souvent elles
s'engagent et puis après on se fait
battre à la porte on se retrouve sdf
donc j'attends un bon moment c'est
plutôt sur la longue durée c'est plutôt
ça ouais là c'est vraiment l'amour
nov la soirée à laquelle vous êtes prêts
à tout faire pour pas y aller ah c'est
bhl et la nrf
pdg et hec ou om et psg
c'est sûrement pas la troisième là ça
c'est sûr non par contre maintenant ça
serait justement de regarder un match om
psg chez bhl avec des pdg
titeuf ce que vous regardez en premier
chez une fille son cv son rib ou son qi
sokü
les trois lettres qui vous font fuir
devant une fille ces mst ou mlf
même et c'est vrai que l'efs nom
isabelle alonso ces coquines d'abord
contrairement à l'image que tu as touché
pas l'image qu'elle veut se donner donc
la valeur sauf pour les plus tôt mlf oui
oui je suis pour je dois regarder une
caméra oui il faut dire elle isabelle si
un jour on se rencontre
en discutera
je ferai pas le match y
être pas tout de suite mais après
alors claude allègre vous avez beaucoup
les sigles vous aimez bien les navettes
mais bien tout ce qui explique tout ce
qui est technocratique
alors on va vous faire une interview
sigle
est
ce que la démocratie a plus à craindre
de letea ou de l'ena
on n'y a pas de photos le taa je veux
dire là le terrorisme non mais le
terrorisme est une chose qu'il faut
éradiquer il ya patriat et ça se compare
pas très bien pour vous la meilleure
illustration du progrès c'est le tgv ou
liv et g
c'est une c'est une très très bonne
question en fait c'est une très bonne
décision à l'aigre et est très difficile
je pense que je pense que
liv et j'essaie quand même c'est quand
même la libération des femmes c'est
quand même plus important ptg que le tgv
est ce que l'environnement est plus
menacé par les ogm ou par les hlm au nom
par les hlm les ogm sa menace personne
complètement cessé c'est un c'est un
fantasme ya aucun accident avec les ogm
les les ogm permettent quand vous pensez
que deschamps ont été saccagés alors
qu'on préparait des vaccins ouais non on
va bien sûr les hlm où il faut il faut
décider de prendre un certain nombre de
banlieue et la gelée raser et de les
reconstruire de reconstruire et et c'est
ce que je proposais avec le budget 2011
lieu de baisser les impôts on aurait dû
faire ça
absolument ce que vous regardez en
priorité chez une fille
son cv
son rib ou son qi
leur hymne sûrement pas que je sais pas
je prends le cul le cuba
dagg avocat alors les trois lettres qui
pourrait vous faire fuir devant une
fille
mst ou mlf
les deux à l'union
aïe aïe aïe la dernière votre vie
sexuelle au long l'année non mais vous
propose lancé jean-claude franchement
y'a pas de soucis votre vie sexuelle
c'est plutôt sas ras ou sos
ras
les messieurs
robert laffont et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
y mettez un peu de bleu